Now with this in place, now here comes the
really interesting question. It’s assignment
number two. And again it’s a programming
assignment – free to skip.
Now that we have a function of flip, it gives
me this list of a thousand outcomes from which
I cannot derive things like the mean. Run this
thing itself a thousand times and each time you
get a different mean, so this means zero, mean
one and so on all the way to a mean nine, nine,nine.
And these means are continuous values
obviously, between zero and one and give you
the same function as before, mean, variance,
standard deviation, and flip and as I scroll
down, I find this function sample, I want you
to put in code over here so that when I sample
with the same n, I run the flip experiment a
thousand times and every single time I compute
the mean and now I assemble a list of all the
means into this thing called outcomes.
The means will be continuous, I can do a history
plot, it’ll be better with many bins, so this
notation over here gives me 30 bins. And to
give you a feel for what to expect, this is
a typical histogram I get out as a result.
It’s really beautiful. If I increase n to 2000,
I get this histogram over here. Apologize some
numbers are a little illegible over here but
the center of it is 0.5 and it falls off to
smaller number to the left, to the right. You
can think of it as a distribution over the
means outcomes of large numbers of coin flips
and has an interesting shape. So go ahead and
program it and see if you can reproduce these
results.